en el vídeo pasado comenzamos con dos
transformaciones lineales la
transformación s que iba de rn a rm y la
transformación de que también iba de rm
r m muy bien entonces a partir de estas
dos transformaciones nosotros definimos
una nueva transformación esto fue una
definición y ahora la transformación s
más te aplicado un vector x esta
transformación sencillamente era el
resultado de sumar s de x con td x era
aplicarle es el vector x y al resultado
sumarle t aplicada al vector x bien
ahora x estaba en rn y sbx itv x están
en r m
así que ese máster ese máster
era una transformación de rn
r m de nuevo bien después fuimos un paso
más lejos dijimos si aceite se pueden
representar mediante matrices que
siempre es el caso cuando se trata de
transformación de finales entonces
podíamos hacer más cosas dijimos bueno
si ese de x se puede representar
mediante una matriz a es decir s de x es
lo mismo que una matriz a por el vector
x donde la matriz a es de m por n puesto
que la transformación va de rn a rm
y hacíamos lo mismo con te decíamos pues
te de equis era lo mismo que una matriz
b por el vector x donde nuevo te va de
rn a rm así que esta matriz b también es
de m por n entonces nosotros dijimos
bueno pues vamos a definir vamos a
definir la suma de las matrices a ive la
suma de dos matrices a y b donde hay b
tienen la misma dimensión esto es
importante ahí ve tiene que tener la
misma
misma dimensión dimensión que en este
caso es m por n
entonces que era esta suma pues
sencillamente era la matriz que se
obtenía de sumar las columnas de a con
las columnas de b la primera columna si
a una es la primera columna de a la
primera columna de hamás b es a uno más
de uno donde ve uno es la primera
columna de la segunda columna de esta
matriz era a dos
más de dos
y así así definimos todo hasta
hasta la enésima columna hasta en más de
n
bien y esto era lo que nosotros
definimos como la suma de la matriz con
la matriz b y la razón motivante detrás
de esto es que si hacíamos esa
definición entonces la matriz que
representaba la transformación ese
master
era sencillamente la matriz a + b es
decir la matriz que representa la suma
en transformaciones es la suma de las
matrices que representan a las
transformaciones individualmente así que
ese máster era lo mismo que la matriz a
más la matriz b todo esa multiplicada
por el vector x bien ahora esto está muy
abstracto así que vamos a hacer un
ejemplo concreto para que veamos cómo
funciona bien hagamos un ejemplo con
matrices de 2 x 2
mi primera matriz va a ser la matriz 13
menos 2 4
y la voy a sumar con la segunda matriz
que va a ser la matriz 2 727 menos 3 - 1
bien y cuanto me da esto pues la
definición que me dice la definición me
dice toma la el primer vector columna de
la primera matriz y suma lo con el
primer vector bo columna de la segunda
matriz eso cuánto sería esto sumar
vectores es simplemente sumar los
entrada a entrada así que esto sería uno
más dos y menos dos más menos 3
qué hay de la segunda columna pues eso
sería la segunda columna el segundo
vector columna de la primera matriz más
el segundo vector columna de la segunda
matriz así que sería 3 + 7
y en segunda entrada 4 menos
muy bien y cuánto es esto pues
simplemente tengo que hacer todas esas
sumas y concluyó que esto es uno más dos
que sería 337 es 10 - 2 - 3 es menos 5 y
4 menos uno es 3
perfecto eso fue fácil y si se fijan lo
único que hice fue sumar todas las
entradas correspondientes en ambas
matrices
así que en realidad si yo escribo a la
matriz
como la matriz a 11 a 12
hasta
a 1 n
y luego a 21 así hasta
2 n
imagínense que continúo escribiendo
hasta a m1
hasta
m m así que aquí en medio hay un montón
de entradas pero no las voy a escribir y
luego la matriz be quien sería pues la
matriz veces y le escribo el mismo modo
sería la matriz de 11 de 12 hasta b1 n y
luego de 21 hasta
hasta de 12 m
si me sigo hacia abajo llegó ave m 1
y por acá hasta de m m
bien entonces quién sería más ve
pues sería vamos a cambiar de color
sería sencillamente sumar la primera
columna de a con la primera columna de b
que sería
a 11 más de 11 a 21 más de 21 y así
continuaría hasta llegar a la m 1 más de
m 1 la segunda columna
la segunda columna sería a 12 + b12
a 22 más de 22 y así hasta a m2 más de
m2 y continuaría continuaría hasta
llegar a la última columna que sería
1 en más de 1 n
a 2 en v2 n continuaría hasta hasta
llegar a m m más de m n así que estas
dos cosas sumar entrada a entrada
equivale a esta anotación que es sumar
columna por columna bien qué pasa ahora
con el producto de una escalar por una
matriz bien pues les recuerdo que
nosotros definimos nosotros definimos lo
que era un escalarse por la
transformación t y aplicada a un vector
x esta nueva transformación era
sencillamente tomar el escalar c y
multiplicarlo por t de x esto también
era una transformación lineal y nosotros
vimos que si definimos el producto de
una escalarse por la matriz a como
simplemente multiplicar el escalar por
cada una de las columnas c por la
primera columna de a c por la segunda
columna de a
y así hasta
hasta que por la última columna de a
entonces esta transformación como te dé
x como te dé x es lo mismo que la matriz
b por el vector x entonces nosotros
teníamos que esto era lo mismo que en la
escalarse por la matriz de multiplicada
por el vector x y esto después de
algunas manipulaciones algebraicas vimos
que era igual a escalar seis por la
matriz b multiplicado por el vector x
así que nosotros queríamos encontrar
esto para poder utilizar esta definición
bien entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo
de una escalar por una matriz vamos a
tomar una matriz de 3 por 2 y el escalar
5 vamos a decir el producto 5 x
la matriz 1 - 1 2 3 7 0
y que me dice la definición pues la
definición me dice simplemente toma tu
escalar y multiplicarlo por cada una de
las columnas si tomo un escalar por un
vector es multiplicar ese escalar por
todas las entradas así que esto sería 5
por 1 que 5 5 por 15 5 por 2 es 10 5 por
7 es 35
y luego la segunda columna es de nuevo
tomo mi 5 y lo multiplicó por este
vector columna 5 por menos 1 es menos 5
5 por 3 es 15 y 5 por 0 es cero
perfecto eso fue incluso más fácil que
sumar dos matrices y de hecho si se
fijan de nuevo el resultado de nuevo el
resultado es multiplicar el escalar por
cada una de las entradas así que en
efecto el escalarse por la matriz a es
igual a si la matriz de nuevo tiene esta
forma es simplemente c por 11 c por a 12
así hasta que por a 1 en la segunda
segunda el segundo renglón sería c por 2
sepor a 22 así hasta hace por 2 n
si continuaría hasta c por a m 1 c por
m2 hasta c por a m n
de nuevo el resultado es simplemente
multiplicar todas las entradas de la
matriz por el escalar c y bueno espero
que estos ejemplos les hayan clarificado
un poco lo que estamos haciendo